c'est un petit coin de paradis du côté
d'un grand de Touren une maison
familiale au milieu des vignes où
Vincent le cuisinier concocte des repas
au gré des saisons selon l'humeur du
jour des volailles des légumes à croqués
en direct du potager ici c'est la
cuisine 0 km tout est à porter de main
on récolte les légumes on fait les
futurs semi on s'occupe de nos volail on
récupère les œufs certains jours c'est
l'abattage et
et voilà c'est une vraie vie c'est un
vrai restaurant de campagne ils sont pas
contents nous on accompagne la nature
c'est-à-dire qu'on laisse faire les
choses il y a des zones en jachè il y a
des c'est finalement on laisse faire
c'est très équilibré on laisse venir des
prédateurs on laisse venir les lapins
les escargots on les récupère parce que
finalement ils finissent dans les
assiettes mijotées et on ne met jamais
des grandes plantations c'est chaque
fois quelques rangs de poireaux quelques
que chou l'équilibre se fait
naturellement bonjour ça va bien chef ça
va tu vas bien très bien vous passé des
bonnes vacances passé bonacances Vincent
et Olivia ont quitté la Belgique il y a
3 ans pour offrir une nouvelle vie à
leurs enfants dans le jardin de la
France propriétaire d'un grand
restaurant gastronomique trop grand ces
professionnels ont voulu retrouver le
goût d'une cuisine et d'un restaurant à
taille humaine pas plus de 15 couvert et
un esprit artisanal respectueux du
terroir une philosophie de vie qui a
séduit les habitant du cru pour quelle
raison parce que il y a d'abord un
accueil chaleureux extraordinaire ce qui
fait que nous sommes nous nous sentons
des amis en quelque sorte donc c'est
tout à fait appréciable pour aussi une
qualité de repas il est tout à fait
sympathique de savoir que ça vient
directement du potager que ce qu'on a
dans son assiette est vraiment tout à
fait nature et puis parce que ce sont
aussi des gens qui se sont parfaitement
intégrés dans le village et qui ont
beaucoup
dynamisé cette petite région notre petit
paradis bourgoillois
voilà 21 janvier 2014 moment inédit est
médiatique un lâché de 200 poules dans
les vignes du domaine une idée innovante
entre Vincent le cuisinier et Philippe
Le Vigneron un partage d'espace entre
végétal et animal pour l'entretien d'une
parcelle expérimentale du bio pour une
cuvé du patron maison et une dynamique
de territoire qui ne fait que
commencer dans des territoires comme les
ntres qui sont un peu détachés des
circuits touristique de masse nous si on
n'est pas en synergie entre différents
corps de métier c'est-à-dire les
quelques sites touristiques qui peut y
avoir les gites les restaurants les
producteurs rien ne peut fonctionner
donc c'est vraiment c'est indispensable
et moi vraiment je milite pour que ce
genre de ce qu'on a mis en place avec
Vincent se développe au un
maximum Jean-Luc
vous venez manger un petit un peu de
frit et puis un coup de rosée la vie
c'est des instants c'est des moments de
partage et à partir du moment on est
bien sur un territoire si on on rayonne
comme ça aussi bien en Touren c'est
qu'on qu'on est bien entre nous quoi h
voilà donc les idées là vont continuer à
germer une par
an sur papier dans la tête il y en a
bien plus non ça après c'est bien beau
d'avoir des idées mais faut les mettre
en en uvre bien oui ouiètement programme
jusque
2022 des trucs que tu m'as pas dit
encore en attendant 2022 les projets
unouristiques fleurissent entre la
Pointe de surréalisme belge et
l'expérience du vigneron encré depuis
plusieurs générations à Bourgueil voilà
tu Mones avec c'est sur le mont sigou
dans un ancien foudre de la famille
Bouar que s'invite les piqueenqu chic so
chic vous êtes seul au monde vous pouvez
aussi manger des raisins après mais il
faut pas le dire au
[Musique]
vigneron je n'ai jamais mangé dans un
tonneau avant mais c'est une nouvelle
expérience Vincent m'a dit qu'on pouvait
encore sentir le
vin je ne suis pas sûr mais peu importe
nous avons à boire il y a des riettes de
poule du confit de canard du boudin noir
du jambon à l'os les œufs évidemment de
nos poules et une terine
d'agneau je pense que ce picnique est
vraiment fabuleux il pourrait servir à
la fois de déjeuner dîner c'est adorable
les produits locaux sont
merveilleux une expérience inoubliable
pour ces touristes britanniques
prochaine étape du partenariat ou plutôt
de l'amitié entre le cuisinier et le
vigneront les vendanges de la prochaine
cuvée de l'enclos des poules et en
janvier une animation taille et toc au
domaine de la galtière l'histoire
s'écrit à quatre mains